In Canada, police in Toronto say a man armed with a handgun...
...shot 14 people late Sunday, killing two of them...
...in an attack that ended with the suspect also dead.
In the United States, President Donald Trump warns Iran...
...to "never threaten the United States,"...
...after the Iranian president said war with Iran...
...would be "the mother of all wars."
In Syria, the government in Damascus has criticized...
...Israel's evacuation of hundreds of volunteer White Helmet rescue workers,...
...condemning it as a "criminal operation."
In China, investigations into a domestic drug manufacturer...
...begin after it is accused of making faulty rabies vaccines...
...that thousands of children may have been injected with.
Finally from Japan, a deadly heatwave has sent temperatures in Kumagaya,...
...just north of Tokyo, to the highest ever recorded in that country:...
...41.1 degrees Celsius.